Wow welcome to this video plague on SCH
from Antarctica yeah all right really
not from Antarctica okay give you for
Kings Indian setup or maybe I can maybe
just switch to something with d5 and c5
not a king's indian again not that it is
a bad opening but I I just lost the last
game from the Kings Indian type of
structure let's just play the center for
once with the e5 coming here yeah here
we go threatening efore already if this
looks this looks quite um comfortable
already
I mean there why doesn't he just ysd
taking 1e5 isn't this like the only move
further thing to take on d4 ID for also
probably must take okay so he allows me
to take the bishop okay I'll do that
should be shouldn't be too bad having a
better central control and the bishop
pair after 30 moves with black okay hmm
but what's the next planet d 4 is a
natural way to continue because the
queen is in the spin but I can still
activate a bit more Queen 85 attacking 1
a 2 and this is really hanging i will
take the pawn if he ignores it okay so
maybe just complete the centralization
here and then go with D form d formats
maybe night see form but ok I've got
Queen a 6 yeah let's let's do that
everything's set up for this move so no
use to to hesitate here efore sd3
winning material here on be 294 Queen 86
and he cannot play e4 and of course 95 I
mean I'm over often I'm often enough on
d4 so you cannot win the pawn
and I had on the clock for once
okay very very difficult to play this
position I'm not quite sure that I'm
threatening something directly but it's
just not very comfortable okay I can
take here now they're not quite sure
what he yeah I happy to have e to the
intermediate okay it's not a waste any
time here yeah it was very very
difficult to play already if not I would
write bad for white white resigns yeah
it was this was really tricky position
already i don't i don't really it
already know if he can still keep
something of a position here computer
wants to play Bishop a one not the most
natural move but it safely protects the
the bishop and I wants to play 985 yeah
black is substantially better I mean he
should be I mean I'm totally centralized
I've got the two bishops it's just a
very good very good position it seems
that here queen bee for was even even a
lot stronger yeah probably because I've
just attacked me three yeah i played
this rather quickly yeah i thought it
does not make much of a difference but
yeah here white has no move really what
should you do everything so this is
hanging as d3 there's a capture it's a
little bit too much yeah the real
problem here was was the opening after
night d 7
he really should react to my idea to
play five and b3 is just totally am yeah
unsuitable reaction as it weakens the
whole diagonal and it's just not helped
at all does not help at all yeah this is
already fantastic position for black
just met out how to how to continue I
mean I played it a bit quick maybe but I
didn't want to get into any time
pressure and this good a position him
because well even the second best move
was probably enough to keep a big edge
alright thanks for watching